uh hi I'm wishi I work for research at
comma uh today I'm going to talk about
uh how we view driving with open pilot
as a human machine uh cooperation progam
and how we use machine learning to
improve
things so this is how we drive uh
without open pilot as a human basically
the driver uh is the only actor here but
with open pilot the the driver's roow
slightly changes and uh they will now
work cohesively with open pilot
uh with the driving model specifically
in some way so today's talk will be uh
focusing on different aspects of the
Dynamics between the human and the
driving model uh shown in this
graph um so we will cover how we use the
power of machine learning to uh learn
about the driver and then learn about
the driving model and how we ship uh
many impactful improvements uh along the
way uh as we know uh open pilot as a
driving assistance system uh requires
the user to be able to take over at all
times uh in simple words you need to pay
attention uh we already covered how
driver monitoring Works uh in open pilot
uh from the last ComiCon uh talk two
years ago so today we'll be focus on the
progress we made since that time so this
is what the driver facing camera looks
like on the old comma 2 uh is a bit
noisy but uh mostly uh it's only shows a
limited wheel of the
interior uh for the driver uh due to a
very small wheel on the comma 2 uh to
make things worse uh due to limited
compute on the comma 2 we had to crop
the image and uh fit it into the model
uh it's not fun to do to build a DM like
on inputs like this trust me uh for the
model it was like watching a movie like
with all the people standing in front of
you like blocking the wheel that's
basically how it felt like uh moving to
the comma 3 this is the initial model we
shipped using uh the comma 2 Data before
we had any real uh amount of comma free
data to train
on uh and this is the new model we
training on uh the new comma free uh
data uh and the model we ship currently
uh it's
shown it's shown with the green box uh
which basically covers the whole
interior instead of just some part of
the driver uh now as we can see we can
see the full body of the driver and hand
and even the steering wheel uh and then
the same is true for also the
passenger uh with that uh now we have
achieved on the comma
free Almost 100% of a phase detection
rate uh with that we can remove the
wheel touch uh when the camera is not
blocked and use Vision only for DM uh
yeah because it's it's not the best idea
to assume the driver is p paying
attention when they are touching the
wheel because that can easily be cheated
like in a Tesla uh so another thing we
can do was to uh remove the right hand
drive tole with the model now can uh now
being able to detect whether uh which
side the driver is driving on uh say
you're in like the US you're on the
right in this image or or you're on the
other side if you're driving on the
wrong side of the road um
so with that we can remove the right
hand drive Targo uh one last TGO is
always better as deep says uh we will
come back to that uh passenger thing a
little bit later um so in terms of uh
true
positive we have achieved a net gain of
almost 2x in true alert true POS true
positives by using a model a bigger
model box and then now we have we also
have the extra benefit of the extra
contacts we have with the full interior
camera
um with the extra context we are able to
build upon it to do this so last time on
my uh ComiCon presentation I mentioned
that we will explore moving to a more
endtoend
approach a more a more endtoend approach
uh for DM uh now I think is a good I
think it's a good time to do that so in
a classic DM policy we have the model
that predicts some attributes of the
driver and then those are fat into some
stay machine to determine whether the
driver is distracted but in the end to
endend DM world the model should be able
to tell from the footage like whether
the driver is paying attention or not
directly so here is an example of the a
deep
driving as you can see other than uh
when he was looking right uh on the at
the row or when he was like straight
distracted by his phone there's also a
lot of great areas there uh as a human
even as a human is tough to tell like
whether sometimes he's paying attention
or not so we need
to Define attention to be able to like
have good ground through for N2 n DM to
learn
from uh here's a hint DM doesn't live in
a vacuum it's part of the system a part
of the open p system so what is
attention
really so the answer the answer really
is quite simple uh we already to know
that open pilot is a driving assistance
system again uh the driver should always
be ready to take control so with that in
mind uh we are ready to get our gr with
that with that in mind it's simple that
the paying
attention definition should be whether
the driver is ready to take control at
any
time with that in mind we're ready to
get our ground through for the end to
end DM system so uh we make two two
simple
assumptions the first one is uh the
probability of taking control is higher
when the driver is driving or taking
control that's pretty obvious and the
second one is uh the probability of not
not taking control is higher when the
car is at a sand
Feld so turns out we already have those
things in the in the locks for a long
time uh therefore you can just use them
to train the model uh to predict from
the driver footage whether uh the driver
is ready to take control or
not um so with
those uh
naive ground Tri adjustment mentioned we
train uh vanilla n2m model that predicts
whether the driver is distracted from uh
some frames and you can see that uh it
sometimes reliably detects uh when the
driver is really distracted like ad was
looking out the window he was definitely
not ready to take control here but the
all the model also thinks ad was not
ready to control here which where he was
just chill driving and so it's this he
was looking at a row while turning the
radio which in a taking control context
is fine so we need to fix those false
positives so we we realize that the only
way to fix all the
ambiguity which it's probably a it's
most likely a finite set is to have the
re a real human to label some of those
difficult scene uh cases uh because of
the fact that uh we already have a
helper model that's trained on vanilla
DM uh labels we can use that model to
find how us find all the interesting
stuff and then only 2% of our enti set
ends up uh needing to be uh labeled to
get the perspective we outsourced the
laboring work to a thir party and it
took them only one person in less than
three days to do our laboring we pay
virtually nothing to uh gain a lot of
improvements in our ground
tro so with that improved ground tro and
our n2n DM model train on that uh the
model is now able to pick up additional
subtle distractions like uh using phone
uh without force triggering on CH
driving poses like in this examples uh
in in this example shown here uh
whenever the timer drops it means the
system things a DE is was distracted so
you can see this is very accurate
because uh the when the timer jobs is
where ad was really not able to uh be a
to take control so uh to put it in a
number with a number um we have metric
showing that the net result of adding
nend to end policy is to have a 15% gain
in false in true positive with no false
positive
gain so now let's uh change our Focus
onto the driver uh by looking at some
behavioral
metrics uh remember in uh fullframe DM I
mentioned earlier we are now able to
detect uh from DM model if there's a
passenger or not so by overlaying that
with the driving data we came to the
surprising conclusion that
um when when people drive alone compared
to driving with passenger they are four
times more likely to take a corner over
half a
g and two and a half times more likely
in uh heart bre
heartbreaking and twice uh as like twice
more likely to uh taate
someone um so
that all that uh
aggressive all that aggressiveness
difference in uh
driving from having a passenger not
inspired us to uh do a whole driving
style analysis on our Fleet we basically
classify driving style using matrics
like heartbreaking uh heart heart
acceleration or like heart turning
Etc and then those things I use as a
conditioner to uh fit into to the
driving model and as Harold mentioned by
using like the chist profile we actually
make uh Taco Bell Drive much easier by
making Drive
smother so another metrics that is super
important to our company is that uh we
need to understand the relation between
making driving chill and potentially
making driving uh more making drivers
more prone to distractions uh as always
we we talk with numbers and we have
metrics for exactly
that um so the first conclusion from our
metric is that uh drivers generally pay
more attention to the role when us W
pilot then not using W pilot oh so here
the green curve shows uh the um
distribution of segments with different
percentage of distracted times when
engage with open p in uh green or not
engage open B in Red so essentially uh
the more left the curve the more left
the curve uh the less distracted the
drivers are
so we can see that uh when engaged uh
drivers are generally less distracted uh
that number actually is around
40% so that's a
big big Improvement so actually it's
actually not too surprising to imagine
these things because with open pilot um
it first takes away the taxing stuff
from driving and allows you to pay more
attention pay more attention to the
surroundings and also it it's hard to
not pay attention when like it yells at
you when you get distracted
um the second one is actually more
interesting uh there's a common doubt
that if You' been using open p for a
long time you start to lose attention
and become complacent and in the long
run so but our long run uh Magic
disagrees with that uh this is an
aggregate of the same bunch of drivers
in the long
term
um distraction Trend Trends and the
lines remain pretty flat uh for
different percen of distraction
durations so we are confident that
um the driver our users don't get more
distracted as time goes
by so now uh with the driver out the way
now Tech uh talk a little about the
driving model itself so the model is a
integral part of the of our human
machine system uh and it's crucial that
we understand how the driver can
interact with it and how it can uh
potentially interact back with the
driver and make the experience more more
coherent
coherent uh the human driver mostly
interacts with the driving model by
disengage by disengaging or overriding
uh those disengagements give us a strong
signals of when and uh hopefully why uh
the model doesn't do well and therefore
we've been putting a lot of effort uh
into building and looking into um this
engagement metrics uh we have been
tracking the longest time uh open pilot
can be engaged which is e uh which is
easily in the in the hours uh it's good
to know open pilot works but this kind
of stuff all look like this and uh it
can't really help us improve it's like
similar to someone uh who learn driving
on the highway only and they can't
really learn anything so the question
have been we have been asking lately a
lot is uh where do open pilot users tend
to take over and we build
this uh this is our automatic
disengagement uh
reports
um so is a tool that enables us to uh do
large scale up to dat dis engage
engagement analysis so it runs steady
automatically and it's shown our on our
biggest TV in research essentially it
gathers all the lateral and longitudal
override data as well as the unexpected
uh disengagements and uh and then with
all the locks uh pared we are able to uh
group group all the disengagements by
the by the dis disagreements between the
human and the model uh so that we can
split in different classes as shown here
and here are just some examples of
different kinds of uh
disengagements
um so basically uh we show a list of
random example for each kind of
disengagements on the reports and then
everything is visualized with the
necessary data uh like in the gifts here
we can see uh in this
report uh there's been turn cutting and
we can like go to the turn cutting
person in comma which is one person and
say turn cutting team which is one
person and say oh there's been a lot of
cutting lately uh what's going on and
then uh hopefully can have it
fixed so here uh here is another example
of how we uh use this report to fix uh
real
complaint so there's
been as people know like there's a lot
of noise about um people asking oh we
need to adjust the following distance is
following too far on the highway
sometimes like this Discord user
Johnson and
uh yeah we we listen to that and but we
need to back that out of data so we look
at the this engagement reports and we
saw this hm there's like uh so you can
see there's a more than 30% of our
longitudal disengagements is due to the
model fallowing too close or it's
breaking too hard too early for a Le car
so we know that this is a real problem
and then by like giving this to the the
right person we were able to figure
out not only this is a real problem but
also we know how much we need to fix
this problem so we come up with uh the
latest longital personality toggle in
our
settings uh so the last point I want to
discuss is um how the driving model can
potentially give feedback back to the
driver to communicate his
uncertainty so uh first of all how do we
know if the the model is uncertain uh
for some given scene so well we can we
can we can try to ask the model itself
since we already have the model output
uh some
disengagement predictions for a given
amount of seconds in the
future
uh so actually here we have Matrix to
that com compares the actual
disengagement disengagement numbers
versus the model predictions and we can
confidently say that they match pretty
well so um we can rely on the model
itself to tell oh whether it's certain
or
not uh here is a spectrum of scenes that
the model is feeling
different degrees of confidence on the
left we have the the boring stuff the
it's just like straight Long Highway
roads and in the middle we have traffic
and some interesting Country Roads and
maybe sitting behind an MPD car at a
traffic
light uh which makes the model more
uncertain and on the right side we have
like things where open scenes where open
product can would probably not work like
merging this UK narrow row or turning
onto this busy street after stop
sign so the first step uh we can do is
to show uncertainty in some kind of uh
confidence indicator in UI this is
actually a work in progress we we're
doing now uh so remember that in uh 0 94
we ship the always on border which means
it always communicates the engagement
status so we're thinking oh why not we
can use that and change that to
something less green when the model is
less
confident so that so say in this example
here it's just like one lane row it
dries fine but here then like 2 seconds
later it sees this
potential Divergence and it becomes less
confident and might might need your
attention so it's nice to have that
dynamic between the model and the driver
and also like say when the bir finally
poops on your car it probably becomes R
so um yeah that was my
[Applause]
talk
all
right hey great talk um couple questions
for you uh what's your overall thought
on this the
long-term uh time and investment that's
going to be spent with DM um as we
actually every day get closer and closer
to level four level five where
conceivably you don't care that if the
driver's asleep or in the back seat
completely what what's what's your
general thought on that uh how that's
going to evolve I mean in the context of
open pilot we probably always we require
the the user to pay attention but in
terms of level four level five I would
say the there will be in the future some
interplay between like how confident the
model feels and how the DM policy should
adapt I think that's the final goal okay
that makes sense so maybe certain times
it might be needed but other times it
would be fine and may alert the user to
hey we need you to probably pay
attention now to be safer but in general
you're okay yeah we already have some
adaptive DM policy uh in place so that
might be a good place to start okay and
then just quick question on um the
actual eye like eye gaze and tracking on
that yes um I know with like uh Tesla
you can just put on sunglasses and it it
says yeah he's paying attention even
though your eyes can be completely
closed um does this system have anything
with like eyewear or glasses that you
know that it's not detecting eyes and
does it assume that you're fine I don't
know if that's it's it's common
knowledge of how that works or not I
think whenever your eyes is invisible
ago it just falls back to a head pose
and uh the end to end policy is actually
really good that when you have some Weir
poses other than you know just normal
driving position say you're sleeping
when you're wearing sunglasses it can
probably pick that up and say oh there's
an anomaly
here great I got a question here in the
back hello awesome talk uh they think
that near symbolic approach with some
something like um propositional logic
will be viable solution for deeper
understanding of actors in
environment uh sorry can you repeat uh
do I think that in future a near
symbolic approach with uh formal logic
declarative logic with the sub symbolic
models will be viable to deeper
understand the uh behavior of actors in
environment to predict future
I'm not sure about symbolic near
symbolic it's like uh deep learning plus
uh declarative logic oh I
see uh I mean our end goal is to have
end to endend driving model that just
looks at the scene and tells us where to
drive and potentially like how confident
it is about like doing this path and I
think in the future as the driving model
gets better it should just be able to
tell like naturally with our end to end
approach does that make
sense I wonder if you could share a
little bit about um how you classify and
what uh breakdowns of data you get from
classifying drivers as chill or not it's
a fascinating topic for me I I I've
gotten old and I use open pilot a lot so
I mostly Drive chill but every once in a
while I throw my car uh on an auto
crosscourse and I use open pilot as a
Data Logger so is there a memory to that
are you classifying per segment per
route per device and uh as a
off-the-wall question uh how many open
pilot users would you say are good
drivers I mean we classify them into
five categories basically um but I don't
think we track like specific Dongo IDs
we more I focus on the route I believe
yeah got anything else wish Shing that
was a lengthy question you satisfied
with the answer
Jason you kind of dodged the one where I
asked how many open pilot users were
good
drivers it'll be op in to share this
with your insurance
comp all right we got a question
upstairs
uh thank you uh if if U if you come back
to like U two slides but in terms of
like giving feedback um to the customer
about uncertainties um communicating
um I'm thinking uh if if it's possible
at all but uh yeah not exactly that but
where where you had like um un certain
um model being certain about specific
and trying to communicate it back to the
to the
driver uh not not this one like uh the
the real like um Mo up of the road like
with a vehicle like the picture like few
more slides uh few more maybe like
forward not not back oh the one with the
driving behavior yeah yeah yeah here no
no no no this one of the last ones like
uh uh which
one yellow oh this one wait no no no no
with with the RO like oh sorry sorry
yeah yeah sorry
so this one uh no no more
more no no you're you're going to the
right direction to to the to the end of
the presentation yellow forward looking
State oh that sorry that's this I'm
thinking uh I don't know if it's
possible at all but it would be nice if
uh if it could also communicate some
areas where it does not want to go like
like for example if there is like
vehicle parked or like you know some
blockage or whatever so like uh like
maybe in like I don't know in the red
yeah we can have a hard cut off like
ideally for like some sketchy of the
scene and say oh you should probably
disengage here and give you a super
short timeout anyway does that make
sense yeah cool stuff thank
you all right
I'm coming over here
hey aome talk um you mentioned you make
some assumptions to determine whether
the driver is attentive yeah like um
like if they're driving they could be
more attentive if they're at a stop
maybe less attentive so I was wondering
like I assume these are neither
conclusive nor do they always hold so in
the future do you think it's possible to
also use data from the driving model
like maybe if someone's drifting out of
the lane or if they stop more suddenly
than the model was do you think that can
be used as a negative signal for the
driver
monitoring uh do you mean when engage or
not um I I guess either way either way
um yeah I think desk stop is a little
bit more far away from like what we're
looking for because in here although
those things might not seem immediately
obvious you can see in the data there's
a distribution shift from say taking
control not or like being stand or not
and we picked up that signal and we
Capital capitalized on on that to
determine whether the driver is ready to
take
over I think that's good enough with
some we find
them uh oh I have like a kind of a
farfetched question but uh have you ever
considered using driver monitoring to
not just communicate like uncertainty
between the model and the human but uh
somehow have the human communicate
intent uh back to the driving model for
example uh during a lane change yeah uh
if the human is looking in the rear view
mirror you could use that as a signal
that the human wants to like is
affirmative that it knows it can turn
that yeah but we cannot always assume
that
there will be a lot of forse positive
so whichever way all right we got
interesting point one last
question do you measure the driver
takeover or disengagement reaction time
somehow in like when models
uh uh open byot the driving for 2 hours
and uh do you see that uh it affects
driver's reaction time in case it he
needs to
disengage uh what's the question again
uh do you measure somehow the uh
driver's reaction time uh does it change
uh if the open B has been driving for
for example two or 3 hours without this
engagements you mean the the DM pressure
of time out mouse or the
model
confidence
SL if if there is an
uh M uh there's oh that uh we don't have
metrics for that but I think like the
the second long-term DM metric is pretty
conclusive
about like people using open Val for a
long
time okay thank you
all right actually we got one one more
question someone over here have a
question we
good all right thank you so much wishing
thank
you